welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and moon knight's connections to
the main events of the mcu have begun to
emerge from nods to wakanda and asgard
among stephen grant's textbooks to
evidence that thanos's snap and the blit
from avengers infinity war and end game
have very much impacted moon knight's
world with the blip relief agency the
grc getting shout out and proof on mark
spector's passport that he must have
survived the snap and the reason that
these mcu easter eggs are so interesting
for moon knight is that this title more
than most other marvel titles has so far
presented itself as a mystery contained
within steven and mark's inner worlds
that we don't know yet what's
objectively real or how long mark and
steven have been this way the very
concepts of time and the past themselves
seem like functions of steven's own
subjective perception of reality so
while we look for an answer for why
stephen and mark's issues seem to have
only now reached this boiling point many
have asked while the passport issue date
confirms mark specter survived the snap
could steven grant or any of mark's
other alters as oscar isaac recently
confirmed there are more than two any of
the others have been snapped out of this
consciousness and only recently returned
as the blitz came to an end which would
complicate mark's possession by khonshu
which would have happened during those
transpiring years now yes this is a
complicated subject to explore but it is
one that gets to the heart of how this
show depicts mark's psychological
condition as well as the way the mcu as
a whole continues to explore the blip's
impact as we saw in one division and the
falcon the winter soldier eternals
hawkeye and maybe now in moon knight
let's start by laying out exactly what
we know about mark's history so far we
know from his passport that mark spectre
was born on march 9 1987 and that that
passport was issued on december 14th
2018. assuming moon night is set in the
year 2025 of the mcu after hawkeye and
no way home which were in december 2024
that would make mark spector 37-38 years
old and someone who aged normally as a
survivor of the snap which occurred in
may 2018 of the mcu timeline we also
know that at some point in the past mark
was involved in some incident that led
to the deaths of a group of
archaeologists at a dig site in egypt
which was presumably what led to him
getting mortally wounded and coming upon
the statue of konchu leading to him
making the deal with that deity to serve
him as his avatar also at some point in
that past mark was married to layla but
when she calls stephen episode 1 she
says i've been texting and calling you
for months indeed mark later tells
steven it's been quote a long time how
long you've been doing this i don't know
a long time i've been lucky long time
but it sounds like it was not just
konshu's possession that made mark
suddenly ghost layla i thought that you
were in danger or kidnapped again i just
kept thinking you know he's got the suit
he's fine and then i thought well what
if he gets ambushed when he's not
wearing it what if he doesn't have it ah
that means layla must have known that
mark had the powers of the moon deity
consho to power up into the moon night
suit and then at some point in the past
when they were together she was totally
okay with that and that really something
else changed after that point that then
led mark to hide from her to set up his
life as steven another exchange sheds
light on this you swore he would not
interfere
i know
i'll handle it you have proven you
cannot i will
ungrateful mark altering the terms of
our agreement ah so we've been wondering
if the show was saying that conscious
possession was the cause of mark's
dissociative identity disorder or if
conscious possessed a man without
realizing that man already had
dissociative identity disorder from a
younger age and this line sounds like it
is the latter that mark already had
d.i.d but kept it from konshu and then
through circumstances outside of mark's
control his steven alter resurfaced
conscious was like
what is this other guy doing in here now
and mark had to assure konchu it's cool
it's cool i can handle this so we come
back to the question what caused steven
to return after konchi began possessing
mark within the past year or so well it
might have been the blip folks but for
it to have been caused by the blip
coming to an end and for steven to have
been one of the life forms that thanos's
snap targeted and dusted steven would
have to be defined as a soul within the
mcu because thanos needed the soul stone
to do this to link with half of all
souls in the universe which is why only
intelligent life was dusted instead of
like you know 50 of the bacteria in our
digestive systems that would have caused
the survivors to [ __ ] themselves to
death
oh god you know as a result of me
watching this stuff forming theories
making connections breaking stuff down
my sleep schedule is all messed up i
stay up super late doing research i wake
up really early trying to score early
tickets so when i need to sleep that
needs to be crucial sleep time i'm
catching up on z's but you know there's
all kinds of lights in my room that just
make it really hard to get totally dark
charging lights lights from the street
outside it's been tough but that's where
the blue blocks remedy sleep mask has
been coming in handy for mr v like we
know blue blocks from their blue light
blocking glasses but their sleep mask
goes farther and blocks out 100 of light
for better sleep it's so soft and has
adjustable eye cups and an adjustable
strap for just the perfect fit it works
for people to sleep on your belly on
your side on your back however you sleep
you're sleeping they're just made from
this breathable material and you can
fully open your eyes while you're
wearing it i'm in the sunken place and i
never want to come up to the surface
good night world
i mean it's just great for improving
sleep or meditation napping travel like
i love it when i want to sleep in or
grab a nap during the day when i try to
sleep on a plane they ship worldwide and
they have other great products like red
light therapy devices so go to
blueblocks.com new rockstars use the
coupon code new rockstars to save twenty
percent that's blueblocks.com that's b l
u b l o x dot com slash new rockstars
and use the coupon code new rockstars to
save twenty percent and really steven's
soleness depends on how seriously this
moon knight series is actually taking
the clinical realities of dissociative
identity disorder because you know based
on the series own marketing they have
casually used terms like identities and
alter egos and in fairness to the series
that is how the comics initially
depicted mark spector and even in more
recent runs that have explored the
mental health angle they still tend to
leave it open to interpretation because
really our understanding of associative
identity disorder is something that has
evolved over time now this show for now
at least at times seems to be embracing
the fun aspects of it like oscar isaac
himself cited physical comedians like
peter sellers for influences for how he
depicted steven grant's physicality but
did acknowledge that the characters
peter sellers would play often didn't
know that they were being funny then
again that is the case for pretty much
all comedic characters they tend to have
a certain lack of self-awareness also
there have been jokes like mark calling
steven's mr knight appearance psycho
colonel sanders but at the same time
it's also exploring the tragic aspect of
his condition what steven's really sad
breakdown at that steakhouse and in
future episodes based on the promo
footage this show will feature mark or
steven in a kind of clinical facility so
at that point we may get some clearer
definitions of what mark is going
through exactly and in the credits of
every episode they list a special thanks
to a mental health consultant and
include a really great psa encouraging
people to seek help really the truth of
dissociative identity disorder is that
it's best to avoid using terms like
personalities alter egos or even
identities because it might imply that
these alters are not fully formed people
but in truth they totally are each alter
has their own memories their own
emotions fears desires speech patterns
habits physical mannerisms essentially
what human beings attribute as one's
sense of self and if this show fully
commits to this clinical understanding
they may establish that each of these
alters has their own soul that steven
grant had a soul and that the soul stone
could have targeted stephen the moment
thanos snapped while leaving mark's soul
and body untouched that might have
caused one or more of mark spector's
altars to disappear for five years and
then mark thinking himself cured might
go on to live a more active life at that
point getting his passport getting
married becoming a mercenary getting
possessed but then when the blip ended
and that alter returned suddenly he
would find himself overwhelmed once more
and konchu might cruelly consider that
an alteration of their agreement
meanwhile poor stephen who already has
totally separate memories from mark
would really struggle to gain context in
a world suddenly five years older like
think about it if he dusted and
re-materialized all while he was
contained within mark's subconscious
that would mean he would not even have
the physical sensation that monica and
elena had he would just wake up to a
world five years older no wonder the guy
is so frustrated with time always
seeming to leap forward and the
implications of steven having a soul
could go even further like imagine what
would happen when a sorcerer knocks moon
knight souls into the astral realm
technically we would see all of the
altars at that point it's just another
reason to be so pumped to see the
stevens meet each other in a midnight
sun's team up steven did clarify last
episode my name's steven with the v as
if to acknowledge there is another
famous super steven in the mcu but with
a ph hey a reminder the best way to
support us here at new rockstars is to
check out our new latest obsession shirt
tomb of the moon god which is available
at newrockstarsmerch.com starting to run
out but when you buy it you'll unlock
the added option write in a custom shout
out for our moon night after show you
can follow me on instagram and twitter
at eavos follow new rockstars subscribe
to new rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
you